it's that time get ready
sharp football in the house making
Chetty let's go I am very excited
Warren Sharpe is here we are looking
like true detective no we're looking
like CSI Charleston South Carolina he's
got a blue steel jacket with a floral
print shirt I'm wearing what looks to be
a salmon slash fuchsia crewneck sweater
and all we have salmon is information
and bombs I love when you're in studio
because I get to get a coffee with you
we do this show we record it Thursday's
around like 11:00 11:30 I find this to
always be an interesting time because
the markets move a lot at this time it
seems like what is it about this time
that there's always action well you got
Wednesday injury reports the first one
that hits the market so that comes like
late in the day on Wednesday right and
then 8:00 a.m. Vegas time is 11:00 a.m.
East Coast time so right around this
point in time everybody's got the injury
stuff that has come out right Wednesday
starts to process it limits rise a
little bit on Thursday oh why does that
happen the closer they get to the game
the more they allow you to bet because
the more confidence they have in their
number so they hate taking action when
they don't have a lot of confidence in
their number right because then they're
in the dark and they're most likely
gonna have more information than the
average bettor
and they and they know like people like
me and others like this is all we do is
just research this so there's no way
that a bookmaker can have more
information better information than I do
right why they make the limits really
small early in the week and as they get
more confidence and they see some of the
sharp guys betting into some of those
members then they're like okay we'll
adjust it now then we'll raise the limit
make sense you know the lines already
adjusted and you can't hammer us that
hard they are very professional at this
yep my watermelon had asked
man that was the best insult I've gotten
along in the best response thanks bro
well listen man what's really
unfortunate as I went home oh my fiance
was laughing and I said why are you
laugh and she goes because you kind of
got a watermelon head ass and I was like
damn but I don't even know what that
means but neither do I uh I went one in
four last week Warren and to me to be up
52 - what was it 52 - 12 or something
like that in the second quarter it was
my first losing week and I just realized
that I started betting on some teams
that I don't want to bet on the Titans
games why am i betting on the Browns I
bet on the Washington football team and
you just you look at it you go there are
so many games out there why did I pick
them the only thing I'm happy about I
didn't bet against the Saints and my
fears came true fourth week in a row
they're incredible I mean when good
teams good teams win great teams cover
and they're wild it's it's crazy oh yeah
I mean their defense is so much better
than what I have forecasted yeah they're
they're really a force to be reckoned
with on that side of the football and
you know Teddy Bridgewater was not that
great at all completes passes when they
have to be completed I still don't
understand how a D coordinator can't
just say we're gonna double Michael
Thomas take him away from Teddy you beat
us with all your other guys we don't
care I mean Kamara wasn't even there but
you know Sean Payton's are really smart
coaches and their defense is playing
lights-out good offensive coordinators
can move around their weapons Kyle did
it with Julio when he was there Sean
does it with Michael Thomas you find
ways really good show today we're gonna
get to the dumbest number that NFL head
coaches believe the dumbest rule that
Warren hears about that makes us go
crazy we're gonna talk about everybody
has that analytic stat that you think oh
this is the one that's indicated
indicative of games we're gonna talk a
little bit about correlation versus
causation we're gonna get back into EDS
are because Warren at the end of the
show I went back and looked gave us four
games where there was an adsr advantage
and all four of those teams won its war
I know I don't want to get too excited
about stats I'm going to talk about how
some
we're done but that's one that we've
shown works and then we're gonna dive
into schedules we're through six weeks
now some teams are about to face an an
easier schedule than they're used to
some are gonna face a harder schedule
it's good for fantasy it's good for this
week a lot of information and then we're
gonna jump into super contests and the
games of the week but you talk to
coaches you work with teams you've also
worked as an advisor and you've heard
other people and other shows and there's
this rule is it the rule of 51 is at 53
explain to people because I hadn't
really heard it until you said it last
night it's kind of evolved over the
years I want to say that Bill Parcells
is the first one who came up with it on
and he said if you play a game in which
you can record at least 51 rushing
attempts plus completions you're going
to win the game so if you are goal is to
get 51 plus rushing attempts and
completions and we feel like we're in
good shape to win this game and
therefore you hear people say this to
you there are still people there are a
lot of people I would venture to say 60%
of the league that's just a total guess
on me more but 60% of the league either
is aware of this rule believes in this
rule whether they speak outwardly about
it or not or has been influenced by this
rule via somebody who was above them
that they tutored underneath or no and
they learned from that person whether
it's a family member or a coach that
they'll ourselves is one of these like
coaching philosophy Mount Rushmore guys
where there there's the Bill Parcells
rule about what quarterbacks have taken
the draft and what you're looking for
there's the Bill Parcells about draft
value there's all this stuff so this
rule of 51 or 53 I wanted Pete Carroll
come out and say some stuff about this
to a lot of yeah I've Brian
Schottenheimer said something about it
but then I did some research and Pete
Carroll was talking about it before even
then and he was saying that
Tom cable was his statistical study room
stop 100% quote Tom cable is my
statistical guru when it comes to this
and he said he said quote he's a
brilliant statistician yes brilliant Tom
cable has ever been called that in his
entire life I have never heard Tom cable
being referred to as a brilliant
statistician but that's exactly what
Pete Carroll came out and said and they
used it there that was before Brian
Schottenheimer even came there yes
I've heard other coaches use it as well
Brian shot numbers talked about 53 being
the rule of 53 you think this is
[ __ ] it is [ __ ] like so this is
a big thing in terms of correlation
versus causation which is one thing that
Warren and most people that are
intelligent and understand statistics
and and odds will talk about which is
there are certain things that just
because that happened when you won does
not mean that's the reason that you won
in burr who's really good with all this
stuff gave me a great example if I moved
to New York in 2007 and then in 2008 the
stock market crashed is that correlation
or causation did the stock market crash
because I got here in 2007 no that's not
what it is and that's what you're saying
is there's a number of games where yes I
guess if you had the lead and then you
ran a lot to like ice the game okay like
it might it might tend to go that way
but that's not the reason you won it's
like when you see the statistic when
they run Ezekiel Elliott 20 times in a
game they win then just run them 20
times to start the game it's that's not
how it works but the scary thing is when
you tell me that you believe that many
coaches still believe that you're
talking to them yeah well it's it's
pretty crazy and you're 100% correct
it is all about correlation versus
causation in in today's football you do
not win games simply by having rushing
attempts when you are leading you can
run the ball more actually we just job
Jerry Jones just came out and talked
about this the other day and it was the
game against the Jets yes we're May with
Steven Jones
the Joneses said I can't believe that we
didn't win this game because usually
when Ezekiel Elliott has 30 carries we
win something along those lines mm-hmm
and I said you know what that shows me
that shows me that he doesn't know why
they win he just knows that when they
win Ezekiel Elliott gets a lot of
rushing attempts right so when they win
when they're winning on the scoreboard
they're able to calm or run plays why
because they don't need to start scoring
a lot of points they can work the clock
in the second half especially in the
fourth quarter right I mean I've heard
like even this is just goes to a lot of
Statistics where we put too much on it
I've heard defensive coaches still care
about total yards allowed like that's a
statistic that's like passed around
facilities and that doesn't seem like a
statistic that's representative of how
the games actually going it it shows you
what happened at the EMA doesn't mean
that's that's how good your defense is
no I I don't like looking at any of the
total statistics you know any of the
things that you can count like counting
statistics like okay here's five yards
here's another five yards
oh so that's ten yards now here's
another 15 yards you know any of those
counting statistics we're just like
counting them up and getting to a
certain number right
those aren't efficiency based statistics
that's just volume based oh you had a 20
yard run here on on 3rd and 30 you know
so that's gonna inflate your rushing
totals so you don't like total yards
allowed you don't like total yards per
game you know like you definitely don't
like total rushing attempts it sounds
like no I mean I'm aware I'm aware of
what they are and obviously from a
fantasy perspective we're not talking
about fantasy right I'm talking right
now right with the 33% about real
football right ok when you're in fantasy
you care about how many targets is this
guy's got I guess how many rushing
attempts is this guy gonna get based on
game flow and they'll he'll be either in
the lead in the fourth quarter so we'll
be able to run the football more right
you care about that for fantasy football
but for real life football and X's and
O's and trying to build a lead like when
I'm working with teams the whole goal of
what I do and my involvement is to try
to help this team win a game and the way
and the way in which I try to help them
win a game is by building a lead as
quickly as possible because we know that
teams who lead at halftime are far more
likely to
percentage it's like 80 75 to 80 percent
Wow of the time that you are leading in
halftime will you win a game so your
your whole thing really is let's jump on
this other team let's control the game
flow let's take a lead and a half time
now there are other statistics that you
do like that are not counting statistics
you like a yards per play you know that
you proprieties early down success rate
which is I think early down success rate
mirrors jumping ahead in a game as well
and then also like EPA I'm over at ESPN
and Mina comms and Dominique Foxworth
are talking about EPA expected points
added am i I feel like this is like the
it statistic right now that people it's
kind of like what they do in the NBA or
they do this with like war Wins Above
Replacement I feel like that's what
they're trying to make this statistic
for the NFL are you seeing this too or
am I just sensitive to it no it is a
fact you know more people are looking at
EPA more people are analyzing games
through the use and through the lens of
EPA so break that what is EPA okay so
expect the points added purple on a per
play basis does the from the line of
scrimmage where you're currently are at
and the play that you call the resulting
yardage that you gained right and then
you're now at a new line of scrimmage
how many expected points did the play
that you called add to your likelihood
gosh it's all really about like
explosion and big plays then well not
not necessarily like you could have
let's say you're on second in five and
you have a eight yard gain and you move
from like the 40 yard line to the 48
yard line right right what EPA looks at
is okay what were your expected points
for this drive if you're on a second and
five at the 40 yard vs. of now you're on
first and ten at the 48 how many more
points are you expected to score on this
drive interest now so when you look at
that what is it good at calculating and
what is it bad at calculating because
this is what I've learned from you every
statistic has a benefit and every
statistic has a flaw and it's about
finding the blend and that's why when
you talk about your models that's why
you guys protect that [ __ ] so much
because you've figured out that you
found these blends that figure out all
the strengths so what's the weakness of
EPA well the weakness of EPA is that it
lives inside the computer verse so to
speak and so it doesn't account for
edges that some teams need to get to
stay on schedule okay so for example
that's a that's a convoluted way to say
it's convoluted way to say give you let
me give you a specific example I had
actual coach talk to me the other day
about why is my EPA not quite as high
and so we went through some of the you
know numbers and that sort of thing and
one of the things that they were doing a
little bit of is you know we were
looking at well they're EPA isn't as
high because when they throw to running
backs it's not as well regarded and he's
like interested why is that and I said
well because what EPA is looking at is
it wants to gain those yards down the
field so it's looking at it and saying
well you should throw to a wide receiver
because a wide receiver is going to gain
more yards per attempt than a running
back is right so like a Bruce Arians
offense might actually be a high EPA
because it's always deep shots to wide
receivers exactly so Yahoo certain floor
for a completion percentage but exactly
right so the but the difference is like
the drawback is that what I know from
watching football and what this coach
knows from calling plays yeah is that
passes to running backs are very
efficient oh that's not your big thing
Warren these running backs in tight ends
across the middle or downs
and they work like a virtual handoff
like a pitch play right except you don't
have the drawbacks of the pitch play
because with the pitch play you
generally have now it's for loss now
gonna be excited for loss and you have
faster linebackers and DBS that Rd
linemen that can get up the field
quicker right now you draw the pass rush
in and you throw the football to the
running behind you're less reliant on
offensive line play which we've seen
over the last two years isn't that great
for the majority of the league right so
there's there's what passing to running
back how to count well four passes to
running backs no and what does is
success rate because success rates
looking at based on the down
the distance to go how did you achieve
that threshold and so on a first and 10
if you get 40% of the yards to go some
people use 50% of the yards to go so you
get 4 yards or do you get 5 yards if you
do then that play successful so it's a
binomial thing it's either successful or
unsuccessful can I ask you a question
that we didn't prepare for it all yeah
this season of you working with coaches
do you feel as though they're more
receptive to your information or that
some of them get a little defensive
where are you right now with that no I
think they're very receptive is it the
most receptive it's ever been for you
yeah how does that feel bro I mean it's
it's it's humbling but at the same time
like I know that I'm putting in the hard
work of course we cover this stuff yeah
and I know that they're valuing it and
when I see it actually on the field and
some of the things that I'm suggesting
but I actually end up happening that's
that's so much more I mean that's better
- that's the best feeling for me general
do you do you really think there are
teams that like if you put out a tweet
about like the 11 personnel usage of the
Browns do you think that it gets back to
those facilities at this point do we
think we're at that stage there are I
don't know specifically about the Browns
just a tiny team yes there's a lot of
people that follow me on Twitter that
have responded to me even some some
coaches gotta get some weird DMS man no
no not too many not too many but there
are like they're aware of it and like
some some guys will text me some guys
from teams will text me yeah and say hey
I read that article on your site I
wanted to talk to you about it or this
or that I [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
so you you told us let our two weeks ago
I think it was with early down success
rate may have been last week actually
about how the two statistics that
correlate not cause 8 the most with wins
was it turnovers and EDS are turnovers
was 81 percent in EDS or was 80 percent
right right and EDS are is early down
success rate which is in terms of its if
its first and 10 and you gain six that's
a successful play on first down the
early downs and it's it's not about can
you be successful on third downs it's
can you avoid third downs completely
that's like how I summed is or is that a
clean way of doing it very clean okay
last week you said the biggest EDS are
advantages was Baltimore over Cincinnati
Minnesota over Philadelphia Washington
over Miami
Pittsburgh over LA what's interesting
there even that Pittsburgh won which was
an underdog all four of them four no
straight up with the advantages we got
done our phone call I looked it up and I
threw this in the dock and I said Warren
I'm gonna need to know your biggest EDS
our matchups this week because we got to
keep this going
where do you want to start first in
terms of the the EDS our advantages this
week well unfortunately this week we've
got a number of favorites a couple big
favorites and I'll just work down the
list the teams that have the biggest
edges so the Buffalo Bills have the
biggest edge from an adsr perspective
this week and that's not surprising 17
point favorites over Miami exactly and
so the Buffalo Bills have the number one
sorry number three defense the number
four offense the Miami Dolphins have the
number twenty nine defense and the
number thirty one off offense but based
upon EDS are massive edge for the
Buffalo Bills is sure a little bit of
trend stuff for you the Dolphins this
season oh and three against the spread
is a huge underdog they didn't cover
against the Patriots death as 18-point
dogs they didn't cover to the Cowboys as
22-point dogs they didn't cover the
Chargers so over the past five years NFL
teams are 21 and 11 against the spread
when favored by two or more touchdowns
that's surprising to me that there are
that much of a successful favorite so
and it's in Buffalo but two big spread
17 it's a real big spread it's not
something that I'm accustomed to laying
at any point no is it number like I'm
not touching it personally okay next
matchup the second most drastic EDS are
advantage yeah and this one also
probably shouldn't be surprising this is
a road favorite of close to double
digits nine after ten San Francisco
49ers over the Washington [ __ ]
absolutely San Francisco just has a
massive edge on both sides of the ball
and we know what the Washington Redskins
are
the interesting issue with the
Washington Redskins is I think that
their ETS are could be changing pretty
soon I think it could be changing for
the worse
unfortunately on offense and the reason
is because of the coaching change that
they made and with the coaching change
that they made came about the fact that
they completely jacked up their run rate
on early downs in the first half they
went 70% run on early downs in the first
half against the Miami Dolphins I know a
lot of the Redskins fans are happy that
they got a victory found Adrian Peterson
we love it man stablished was right he
we just got to run the ball give it to
our best guy Adrian Peterson behind
playing Miami so it's like not even
affair you're playing the Miami Dolphins
yeah and guess what all that running 70
percent on early downs of the first half
guess what it got you a seven-to-three
lead at halftime
whoop-dee-doo over the team that doesn't
even want to win games they know Miami
Dolphins I've been on Washington they
didn't cover right so and now they're
going up against San Francisco with
maybe the best defensive line in the NFL
that's just swallowing running backs so
fast forward to the second hand Chris
Thompson has a toe injury as he did he
practice Wednesday I think yeah I think
he was either limited or didn't practice
so they actually continued in the second
half with a 70% early down run rate Wow
and they almost lost the game that's
right they almost right Ryan Fitzpatrick
almost converted a two-point conversion
to beat them so all the fans and and and
and you know the media I think a lot of
the media their eyes are open they're
woke do this rushing is not the way to
win games but it'll be interesting to
see the reason why I said things might
start to get worse for the early to on
success rate is because of the simple
fact that when you're running the ball
so much especially against a good run
defense like the 49ers you are not going
to be bypassing very many third downs
49ers defense right now allowing three
point nine eight yards per carry one of
the best ratios in the league Washington
by the way in their last five games as a
home underdog oh and five straight up oh
and five against the spread and guess
what it's also a Kyle Shanahan revenge
game and Kyle loves revenge did you hear
his quotes
oh yeah what was your favorite part
about working in Washington working with
my dad what was your least favorite part
everything else yeah so accurate
I mean intelligent people do not enjoy
working at places that aren't good
environments for intelligent people and
when Daniel Snyder comes out and says
I'm not firing Bruce Allen when Jay
Glazer comes out and says that's Daniel
Snyder's beer and wings buddy let me
just tell you something
Washington is a team to fade for like
the rest of time I have my under six
ticket before the season do you have
yours six and a half oh excuse me so
that's their value Orange sharp
okay so then Buffalo is a drastic EDS
EDS our advantage San Francisco is
what's your third most drastic EDS are
advantage okay the third one on the
docket this one is actually a closer
game so that'll be nice it's actually an
underdog it's the New Orleans Saints
interesting so the New Orleans Saints
surprisingly enough because we've talked
about how Chicago's defense has been so
good right for years yeah
Chicago's defense has been incredible
but in actuality based upon EDS are
Chicago's defense right now only ranks
23rd in the league and let me add on the
fact that Hakeem Hicks just went onto
the IR I'd only give a shout-out to I
think Evans Silva had it in one of his
matchup columns in terms of Buster's
screen has been a huge liability for
this past defense right now and Fuller's
having somewhat of a Down season so that
kind of backs that up but what else are
you seeing with this EDS because I
thought Chicago's defense was still
playing well other than the Raiders game
well on early downs they're not and
that's the issue they're not forcing as
many teams into those third downs last
season they were forcing teams left and
right into third downs and what happens
when you force the team into third downs
is a lot of times they don't convert
then they're punting the ball back to
you if you're if you're they're
bypassing third downs you're not going
to get those punts right so that's a big
deal and of course their offense has
struggled tremendously they've ranked
30th offensively right now will Mitchell
true Biscay be back at quarterback this
week hopefully for the Bears he will but
I mean he's definitely a little bit of
an upgrade over the current situation
but we know he also was struggling and
it's
Saints defense like we just talked about
how good they've been playing yeah so
the Saints right now they ranked as the
number five defense based upon EDS our
Wow and the number 22 offensive course
their offense isn't going to be as high
because of Teddy Bridgewater's influence
there which we wish that they were a
little bit more efficient but that would
take him to be a little bit more
accurate but you know the surprising
thing is that they are sixth defensively
in just pure unschedule adjusted EDS are
but when you factor in the offenses they
face they move up to fifth so very
strong defensive effort by the New
Orleans Saints I think the other loss
that not a lot of people focused on
earlier this week was the Bears putting
Kyle long on IR I mean do not
underestimate good offensive and
defensive lineman's this league look at
the Kansas City Chiefs with it without
Chris Jones it's a different team one
little nugget about this game both teams
are very good in the trends the Bears at
home in their last 25 home games
eighteen six and one against the spread
but the Saints in their last 20 games in
October are 19 and 1 straight up and
against the spread my only note there
that's kind of when Drew Brees starts
clicking and we're dealing with Teddy
Bridgewater not Drew Brees it's still a
wild statistic yeah like that kind of
record in one month I don't know that's
when they always click so ok that's an
interesting one and it's close and I
think the line the over-under is at 38
it's gonna be tough to score especially
if Alvin Kamara has a high ankle sprain
and it's Mitchell sure Brisky against
the Saints defense under look sweet I
know it's a low number already but maybe
you go first half under I don't know
what that is yeah there's a first half I
think that there are a couple of 20s
there they're tough to get though yeah
like [ __ ] I get I get 20s on 42 not 38
that's crazy
okay so the last one for the EDS are
you've already given us an upset one in
New Orleans what's the last one last one
is the Giants versus the Arizona
Cardinals I know the Arizona Cardinals
offense has been clicking a little bit
better to the last couple of weeks
because who has the advantage here the
Giants okay the Giants have the
advantage actually and this is we talked
about on your show either last week or
the week before
but the Giants are number eight
offensively in eds I mean it's like just
the shock of the century that the Giants
would be number eight but they are they
are they've played some very good
defenses against Edie SR and so they're
very justed rate as their adjusted rate
is that much better and then defensively
the Giants ranked 17th the Atlanta's are
the Arizona Cardinals 29th offense in
the 23rd defense so there's a nice edge
the Giants are laying three points at
home and they have a the fourth highest
EDS are edge of any team this weekend so
this is one of those matchups where you
look at the weapons on the Giants and
you go
Daniel Jones might have a little bit
more time I mean he just played the
Patriots before that he was against the
Minnesota Vikings he's had to play some
tough defenses lately he didn't look
good against Washington either this
seems like the first defense where we've
seen a lot of teams face Arizona now
Patrick Peterson is back you had one guy
changed that much or is that kind of
overstating it I don't think it's
overstating it it definitely is a factor
I mean when you take a one of the best
defensive players and he's not there for
weeks because of suspension and now he's
back it is definitely a factor okay I
have one question for you the Cardinals
run game has been pretty phenomenal thus
far this year and the Giants in the last
five games are allowing four point eight
one yards per carry
is this a game where you think both
offenses could have success yeah there's
a good chance I mean the Arizona
Cardinals have played a couple terrible
defenses like that's the big difference
in this game look at the last two weeks
the Arizona Cardinals have played the
Cincinnati Bengals defense and the
Atlanta Falcons defense two of like the
worst defenses in the NFL based upon
past defensive efficiency those teams
ranked 30th and 31st meanwhile the New
York Giants have played the New England
Patriots and the Minnesota Vikings both
of those teams are top ten past defenses
so Arizona is off of sorry the Giants
are off of two very difficult defenses
now they get a super easy one in Arizona
whereas the Arizona Cardinals have
looked a lot better than
couple weeks and that's come against
crappy defenses unfortunately for the
Giants they are also a crappy defenses
so things might continue to roll for the
Arizona Cardinals
it does look positive for both of these
teams from a ability to produce against
the opponent and you look at the Giants
they're getting back Saeko Barkley
navigated back Evan Engram so they've
got some weapons there that they're that
should be healthy for this game that
they didn't have before Arizona has
allowed monster games this year to tight
ends monster all I got to do is say TJ
Hawkinson number week one yeah it's been
like that every week go look at all the
tight ends and now you could have an
Ingram it that's a that's like a daily
fantasy one that I've circled a lot
Daniel Jones is also one of those
probably underrated plays and he might
be able to rack up some points and no
one's even thinking about it what you
brought up though in terms of schedules
is what we're gonna get into right now
we believe very strongly in strength of
schedule I'm hearing people bringing it
up when they talk about is New England
that good who have they played are the
Niners that good who have they played
but I think it's important to look
towards the future and also this week so
that we can give some people a little
bit of fantasy advice maybe invest in a
buy low for a team that's gonna face
softer running defenses than they had I
think it's gonna be some interesting
gambling stuff also but I think
schedules interesting so let's go
passing offenses that get easier for the
rest of the season compared to what they
faced already what's the most drastic
change for a team in the NFL this guy
right here ooh
the mustache Gardner Minshew okay
Gardner Minshew
is for the Jacksonville Jaguars they
have actually played the number one most
difficult schedule of past defenses to
date really if you rattle them off I
mean they face the Saints the Panthers
the Broncos the Titans the Texans and
the Chiefs who actually have a good past
even terrible against the run good pass
defense every single opponent that I
just mentioned top 14 and past defense
this week they get to face one of the
easiest pass defenses in the NFL the
Cincinnati Bengals your 30th but moving
forward they face the number one easiest
schedule of past defenses the rest of
the year so here
that gardener in the first six weeks
faced the number one most difficult past
defense schedule and then from here on
out he faces the number one easiest pass
defensive skid right of all DJ charkh is
still like leading the NFL and in
expected air yards Wow
yeah so the Chargers offense might go
through a little passing boom right now
did Jaguars yeah the Jaguars very much
charger sorry that's okay the Jaguars I
mean this week against the Bengals a
perfect time to have a nice explosion
and then after that you know they do
place play the Texans again they do have
to play the Titans again but they've got
a lot of past defenses that are workable
that they are going to be able to see
better production week 16 Atlanta
Falcons dial it up it's gonna be great
okay how about the passing offense
that's gonna get a lot harder the rest
of the way maybe it's been easier the
first six weeks and maybe we've inflated
a little bit too much and it's about to
come back down there yeah this one's
interesting because it's the Baltimore
Ravens and I've been a big fan of Lamar
Jackson but the truth is that he's faced
only two past defenses that ranked above
18th over the first six weeks of the
season and only three he's faced three
that ranked bottom five Wow the rest of
the year they faced seven past defenses
that ranked above 18th he only played
two previously now he's got to face
seven and he gets only one defense past
defense that ranks bottom ten he played
three that ranked bottom five right
Dolphins Cardinals Bengals he's had a
few cake walks and I forgot he's got New
England coming up he's got San Francisco
coming up he's got Buffalo coming up
Pittsburgh the Texans man so when you
see that do you kind of go I'm gonna
lower my expectations like all this like
oh Lamar's in the MVP conversation
you're like kind of slow your roll it
could get bumpy really quick absolutely
not enough people out there that's why
we're sharing this with the 33% not
enough people out there factor in season
schedule strength to schedule into their
projections into their bedding into
their understanding of things even if
it's like betting on futures I sure hang
with MVP odds passing leader odds in
season betting definitely you need to be
factoring in strength of schedule and
by the way all these things that we're
sharing this is not some proprietary
thing that's like I'm hiding and I'm
only sharing with the 33% although we
love to give these guys a little bit of
Nuggets this is all up on sharp football
stats comm it's free for everybody to
check out yeah you just go to like
straight you just go to like defense
strength of schedule and then you go to
the bottom and you can organize it you
can prepare all the way I do it all the
time it's phenomenal is there a team
that it's getting a lot harder for them
just this week we're like it what
they've played the first six weeks
compared to this week it's gonna get a
lot harder this week yeah definitely the
Washington Redskins gotcha
the Washington Redskins we just talked
about them they've played the 11th
easiest past defenses year-to-date the
11th easiest schedule of past defenses
now they face the number one in the San
Francisco 49ers so a hundred percent
without a shadow of a doubt that team is
definitely going to be luckily though
Bill Callahan is not gonna run the ball
so I mean doctor to pass the ball so it
doesn't even matter okay how about this
is gonna be a little bit more fantasy
stuff is there a team that's faced a
tough amount of run defenses the first
six weeks and now it's gonna get a lot
easier for that offensive line and
running backs going forward the rest of
the year yes the rushing offense that
has faced the most difficult schedule so
far has been the Minnesota Vikings which
a lot of people are gonna be shocked
about because the Vikings have actually
been pretty good
they rink right now ninth in efficiency
number one in rushing explosiveness
despite playing the number one toughest
schedule of explosive run defenses they
have faced four run defenses this year
that ranked top eight in the NFL they
faced only one the rest of the season
they will face only one top eight run
defense all from from week seven onward
they play your telephone that's our
fancy hook is gonna go more off than he
already is absolutely yes Warren last
week they played the number to
Philadelphia Eagles before that they
played the Giants who are decent against
around 13th they played three top ten
run defenses over the first four weeks
of the season the Falcons the Raiders
Raiders and the Bears yeah they don't
they don't play the Bears until week 17
which for if you're playing fantasy
football
that's awesome doesn't matter and the
rest of the schedule they're playing all
teams that ranked 14th or worse most of
them are below average they're 17th or
watch there's only play one team that's
top 14 that's the Denver Broncos week 11
all right so Dalvin cook 2,000 yards you
here to here first it's gonna happen now
I'm just kidding
what about this week who's faced the
tough run defenses for the the whole
year and then this week it gets easier
this week it's going to get easier for
the Buffalo Bills they've played the
fourth toughest schedule of run defenses
year today and they're getting dance
now they play Devin Singletary could
explode against the number 30 ranked
Miami Dolphins okay and that you know
what's interesting is I'm seeing a lot
of the teams popping up from your EDS
are so it's it's that I'm sure relation
that's pretty awesome that's is that
correlation yeah innovation in this case
I'm gonna get a t-shirt that just says
I'm correlation you're causation back
the [ __ ] off okay
now let's go to the defensive side of
the ball when it comes to running what
defenses have faced a running offense
that's been maybe easy all year and it's
about to get harder the rest of the way
this one is also surprising because this
is rushing offenses right let's do sorry
sorry sorry so these are rushing
offenses where it's been hard all year
and it's no no what am I doing wrong
here let's share the rushing offenses
let's share the rushing offenses that
will get harder for the rest of the
season but has not been too bad your
cockiness
so Dalvin cook it was hard and now it's
getting easy the running offense is
where it's been easy and now it's gonna
get hard
thank you for solving my brain the
Detroit Lions on Christ Johnson because
the Detroit Lions actually haven't been
that great running the football they did
well against the Green Bay Packers but a
lot of teams are doing well against the
Green Bay Packers their run offense
actually so far the season ranks fifth
worst despite playing the fourth easiest
schedule of run defenses they ranked the
fifth worst 28 in the league they like
to run the ball a fair amount right the
Detroit Lions want to be this run based
offense but they ranked 28th despite
playing the fourth easiest schedule
they're about to face the second
toughest
schedule of run defenses over the course
of the rest of the year they faced four
run defenses that ranked bottom 11 in
their first five games played only one
run defense ranked top 20 the right they
slay the Cardinals the Chiefs the
Chargers the Packers and now they're
about to go bears twice
Vikings twice it's gonna get rough it's
gonna get real rough they also play the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers the best run
defense in the league they play them
later this season is this a situation
where you look at people when we're
talking about like wildcard
possibilities and stuff is it this is
this drastic enough of a change where
you go I'm worried about the Lions being
able to compete consistently offensively
because of a change like this yes
absolutely I think that they're going to
be in for a world of difference because
so much of their offense and their
philosophy is built upon the run game
now I love some of the other things that
they've been doing yes the things that
they've been doing that I really like
have been this deep passing on first
down we saw the flyer calmly flicker I
was like amazing veins right it was
amazing they're throwing the ball down
the field Matthew Stafford he's
completing a lot more passes past the
sticks Holliday is pushing it down so
all of that will still be beneficial to
them they actually may need to adjust
their philosophy and rely more on that
but the fact of the matter is this is
definitely a team that's going to be in
for a big shock as it relates to their
ability to run the football and do the
types of things that they want to do and
especially what they've been successful
doing so far this season they've run the
ball a lot so far the season is bad run
defenses now they're gonna be in facing
a lot of good run defenses this week
they face the Vikings the Vikings
defense right now ranks top 10 in sacks
and top 7 in quarterback hits so we're
gonna see how Matt Stafford can do under
a lot more pressure because we talked a
lot about the phantom calls of the refs
in that Lions Packers game but you can
also talk about this Preston and
za'darius Smith we're all over Matt
Stafford in the second half of that game
all over it and we can talk about how
great of signings have been at the same
point that Lions offensive line maybe
hasn't faced the toughest defenses yet
it's gonna get a little bit interesting
okay now we can focus on defenses which
is where my brain was going last time
and we're gonna do this as a whole not
just running and passing but the
defenses as a whole defenses that have
faced very tough offenses for the first
six weeks and maybe this defense is
going to get a lot better from week
seven on who jumped out right away for
you for strength of schedule the Miami
Dolphins have faced the fifth toughest
schedule of offenses so far this year
the second part of your question no I
don't necessarily agree with I don't
know that they're gonna get a lot better
right but they probably are going to
help their offense a bit more they're
still going to struggle is there a
chance that they're facing the toughest
offenses because every offense that
plays them has a lot of success there is
a little bit of that that like factors
into the numbers at the beginning of the
year when the sample size is smaller so
they've really played a handful of games
those offenses have had success so those
offenses tend to do better but obviously
this metric you know factors in all the
other games that those teams are
probably right in addition but certainly
the Miami Dolphins will face a little
bit easier schedule they do face the
number one easiest schedule of offense
is the rest of the year interest only
their defense could look a little bit
better but like let's let's let's you
know not get me to me that makes a
little bit to me that makes me think and
I don't know if it's Buffalo this week
because I get I'm not touching that it's
sort of figuring out the weeks where
that line gets so inflated because
they're winless and they're the Miami
Dolphins to where you go oh this isn't
an offense out there this is a much
easier offense they're used to facing
maybe I'll jump on I just don't have
been on the Dolphins okay what about
this week alone a defense that's faced
really tough offenses all year and now
faced an easier offense this week well
the New Orleans Saints go back to the
ESRC dsr Saints they've played the
second toughest schedule of offenses so
far this year a lot of people don't
realize that the Seahawks have one of
the best offenses in the NFL but they do
they've played them they played the
Texans they played the Cowboys they
played the Rams they played the bucks
and the Jags are surprisingly better
than average offense despite playing a
pretty difficult schedule now they get
the Chicago Bears
a struggling Chicago Bears offense that
might be going back to Mitchell true
Biscay that hopefully is a smooth
transition for them but it's a bumpy
road in Chicago when Mitchell true
Biscay is your quarterback the hell
knows how he's gonna pull that naggy has
to micromanage him he sometimes calls a
ton of runs sometimes he goes you know
what I want to Rico and get 10 touches
today like it there's no rhyme or reason
to this offense st. Stephens is great
okay they got a good opportunity this
week to work towards that under that you
were suggesting I love unders I love
them I love unders I don't watch the
games but I'll bet unders I'll watch
games that I think are overs but I don't
watch games I hate sweating points you
want C unders is a pessimistic you have
to take a pessimistic approach to the
game like yeah there everybody screws up
but only doing so in the offensive side
of the field because you can't have
turnovers I'm right close to your
endzone so you have to basically root
against anything that's good that like
all the fantasy players are rooting for
you basically have to like go against if
you're sitting at a bar and everybody's
rooting for their fantasy guy you have
to like root against every single one of
those guys like think like the Lions
Eagles first half under when there was a
kick return for a touchdown and the
worst part was it was an early part of a
1 o'clock game so that was the highlight
that they kept breaking in yeah it was
it was like one of the first it was in
the first quarter yeah so it's like I
can hear third it's like alright let's
go to charissa Thompson with a Fox News
break Oh craziness in Philadelphia Jamal
Agnew takes a kick return for a
touchdown and I'm seeing on every
television yeah and I'm like
[ __ ] my under is [ __ ] already
because of that and that's the worst
part about watching and under is any
success is death but the actuality is
that you have the same type of
psychological effect when you're rooting
for Andover and there's no points being
scored but the difference like the over
in the Niners Rams game right and Jimmy
G throws a pick in the end zone and then
the Rams go for fourth and goal and they
don't get it and you go that's 14 points
that I'm never gonna get right they're
never gonna get back and it's probably
going to be the demons saying Ravens
Cardinals the amount of times that the
Cardinals kick field goals inside the
five yeah you're like
this like I can absorb one of these I I
usually like absorb like I can absorb
one of these maybe two I'm not gonna
it's not gonna work unless this happens
you know unless I get this so yeah it
does work yeah psychologically the same
manner but our brains are hard-wired to
think more optimistically about the game
which is why more people find it
difficult to root for unders which is
why the public tends to bet overs now
it's not to say I don't play overs or
unders I play everyone whatever the
numbers whatever the model suggests I'm
gonna play it sure but definitely a lot
of the public who don't does not have a
model finds it a lot easier to bet over
is thinking optimistically I want to
just end this on a positive note but
then also when Tom Brady throws an
interception to Micah Hyde and I hit my
under first half in the endzone it's a
beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
that was laid under okay so let's go
we'll finish it up with strength of
schedule with defenses that maybe I've
had it easy for the first six weeks and
it's about to get a lot harder in terms
of the offenses they're facing what's
the biggest drastic change for the rest
of the year well unfortunately the
biggest one is the New England Patriots
and Patriots have played far and away
the easiest schedule year to date in the
NFL of opposing offenses and we knew
that going into the season we knew their
schedule is going to be pretty much of a
cakewalk they haven't faced a single
team outside the bottom ten in offensive
efficiency they've played the Miami
Dolphins the Jets without Sam Darnell
but played the Jets with Sam's Arnold
this week which will probably maybe hint
there could be a little bit of value
there the Redskins the Giants the
Steelers and the bills now they get now
they have to face a league average
schedule so League average is not I mean
they still have such a good defense that
they could dispatch with the league
average schedule although they do have
games against top ten offenses of the
Chiefs the Eagles the Dallas Cowboys and
the Baltimore Ravens upcoming
interesting all right how about just
this week who is it getting them the
most difficult for this week
Philadelphia Eagles unfortunately your
team oh no they've played the night the
easiest schedule of opposing defenses so
far this year and now they have faced
assuming of opposing offenses you're
right yep now
have to face the Dallas Cowboys who have
a good offense
you know it's fallen on tough gets
interesting one so that's where like
this is looking at year-to-date overall
rankings so I factored last few weeks
have not been that good for the Dallas
Cowboys offense and now if you look at
this particular matchup that's gonna
break down momentarily yeah two tackles
maybe out number one wide receiver Amari
Cooper may be out yes that's gonna
change how good this offense is and you
helped the Philadelphia Eagles defense
good producing you are right we're gonna
spend more time on that in a second but
let me get back to the point you just
made about Sam Darden the Patriots cuz I
don't think we're gonna touch on this
game again because the Patriots have
played such an easy schedule because
Adam GaSe and Sam darn old connected on
a 92 yard pass to Robby Andersen and a
number of underneath routes to Jameson
Crowder people were singing their
praises all week what is the little edge
there you think in that Patriots Jets
game that people aren't seeing well this
is a Monday night game we normally don't
talk too much about Monday night games
but the Jets defense has been playing
pretty good overall and if you remember
what they did in the first half against
the Patriots this is a team when because
they already played the Patriots this is
a team that's been put in some very
difficult predicaments Luke offensives
they're cool because two quarterbacks so
they're always going three and out there
always punting the ball they're always
in bad position they never can give up
points because Eagles scored two
defensive touchdowns and their loss
right and so you get these situations
where the defense mentally is worn down
before the game even starts they hate
their quarterback they know the game's
gonna come down to them getting any type
of stop they know it's going to be
impossible to get those stops
consistently and they know they're gonna
lose heading into the game here they
actually think that they have hope they
got Sam Donald back his first game off a
mano
he played pretty well yeah he obviously
is going up against a very difficult New
England Patriots defense but they are
playing at home and they are catching 10
points this is not the game that I would
want to be laying the New England
Patriots just my own personal opinion if
the line was a little bit lower if if I
couldn't get the 10 I might look to get
the Jets in the first half
one reason why Bill Belichick's halftime
adjustments have been phenomenal which
is where the last thing you want is to
have to sweat out the second half with
Bella check with 15 minutes to
completely figure out Gregg Williams
maybe Gregg can shock him in the first
half and he adjusts yeah you're right
why would you bet against the Patriots
for a full game it's hard if you can get
the 10 because that's the key somewhat
of a key number yeah you you may want to
look that way but if it's down to 9
we'll see where it gets when you know on
Friday and Saturday when people go to
looker but if this gets down to 9 that's
when I might be looking more so at the
first I thought unfortunately the first
half's not a nice 7 it's a 6 but it's
still you only you can get in and out
you know you dip your toe in the pool
like we talked about with the New
Orleans Saints
Teddy Bridgewater playing up in the up
in Seattle and the Pacific Northwest
take a shot but take the full game but I
felt like we could dip our toe in the
water do okay in that first half not
enough to deal with Teddy Bridgewater
trying to this feels like the year of
first half for you I feel like you
changed your whole philosophy and said
I'm a first half guy now some sides I'm
doing a little bit more first half but
I've always done totals first half there
have been some years where and I get
your money micro analyze everything and
some years I would be doing full game
and first half together I'm actually
like a little parlay not a part of that
not a partly but I'm doing first half
and full game I'm splitting the wager
and I might be looking to do that on a
game this week every game is unique you
might go one side for the first half and
then the other side for the full game no
no I was that your nutjob
no definitely not doing that because
there's why you do that but know this
this is this is like on a total so if
there's a total that I wanted to hit
first half and full game and there's
enough logical reasoning why I would
want to I think the full game's good my
model likes the full game but I like the
first half a little bit more because of
these other factors then I might want to
go and split my wager and put half on
the first half and the other half on the
full game I dig it
alright so we went through and we looked
at the one o'clock the four clocks and
of course I'm gonna football and decided
that of the five or six matchups Thank
You scheduling people for finally
creating some normalcy Raiders Packers
is maybe the most interesting one both
teams are over 500 we'll see what
happens again we're recording on
Thursday so we don't know what happened
with that the Chiefs last night Raiders
are kind of still in the NFC West
Packers are an interesting team and you
look at it and you go
the Raiders running offense with gabe
jackson coming back against this packers
run defense it's in Lambeau but it's an
interesting matchup so what jumped out
to you right away in this matchup
warrant it's definitely the rushing edge
it's definitely the rushing edge that's
the first thing for the Oakland jumped
out to you too that jumped out to me and
then the second thing is just the
overall schedule that the Oakland
Raiders have played so far this year I
mean go back and look at who they faced
they have played defenses like the
Chicago Bears the Minnesota Vikings the
Denver Broncos the Indianapolis Colts
and then you throw in the Kansas City
Chiefs who are terrible against the run
really good against the past
so overall they've played the fourth
most difficult schedule of opposing
defenses the number one most difficult
schedule of opposing past defense Wow
so Oakland has you know they started off
want to know then they lost two straight
and they came back they beat the Colts
in a really good spot for them a really
terrible spot for the Colts and then
they went to London and shocked me with
everyone with the ability for them to
get up and jump out to that early lead
on the Chicago Bears and then hang on
come-from-behind late and win that game
outright that was definitely a surprise
for me so they do have a rushing edge
here in this game if you look at the
Green Bay Packers defense they've played
a below-average schedule of opposing run
offenses and they ranked 26th in rushing
efficiency they ranked 25th and
explosive run rate they've played the
26th toughest schedule of explosive run
defense and the biggest offensive lie on
the NFL is about to come to town as long
as this this is one game okay where it
is absolutely a must
just like I tweeted out about the
Detroit Lions game heading into the
Monday Night Football game that Green
Bay just played it is an absolute
necessity that Oakland can keep this
game close
early if Oakland can keep this game
close early they're gonna be able to run
the ball in the second half what Green
Bay has thrived on doing through play
calling and scheme jumping out to a lead
the first if jumping out to those big
leads and then letting Preston Smith and
za'darius Smith attack in the second
half exactly and it minimizes the fact
that you've got a crappy run defense
because the other team has to abandon
the run and pass the football and you've
got a good pass deep that was was so
interesting about the Raiders and that
Bears game was even in their comeback
they stayed true to the run Jon Gruden
has stayed true the run with Josh Jacobs
but it was a one score game yeah true
surgery they weren't down but and and do
you think Aaron Rodgers because looking
at how the Raiders have been against
past defense that was like the opening I
saw for the Packers was but but then
again we don't know if we're getting
Davante Adams we don't know if we're
getting Marquez Valdez scantling we
don't know if we're getting Geronimo
Allyson but it does seem like the
Packers might have an advantage in that
side but they definitely do that's the
biggest concern I have for backing the
Oakland Raiders is the passing offense
and the Oakland Raiders struggled to
stop a nosebleed I mean the fact that
they did pretty good against the Chicago
Bears a crappy pass offense does not
really make me feel scared I think they
played the Colts when the Colts were
without T Y Hilton right and if you
remember back to those games against the
Chiefs and the Vikings they won those
games I mean the the the Oakland Raiders
lost those games pretty handedly yeah
and why they lose those handedly because
the other teams jumped out too early
leads they were forced to abandon the
run right they only scored like 10
points one game 14 the other but their
defense led up 28 points and 1 and 34
and the other the games weren't close
they were just throw on the football and
look at who they have offensively I
think they're number one wide receiver
Tyrell Williams is probably out this
week and so they're gonna be relying a
lot on Taita and Darren Waller now
fortunately the Green Bay Packers
they're an interesting team from a tight
end perspective they allow I believe
it's a 63 percent success rate to tight
ends which is like the fourth worst it
ranks 29th in the league but in terms of
a yards per attempt they're the third
best pass defense against tight ends
allowing only like 6.1 or 6.2 cards per
attempt so it's really strange that you
would have a really high success rate
like you're allowing a lot of successful
passes but a really
low yards per play which tells me that
teams are like going after their tight
ends on like third and short or in more
short yardage situations and and not
targeting their tight ends on the you
know the situations where they need a
lot more yards to gain I think one
little nugget that we've talked about
before to add on Raiders are coming off
of a Buy and they're on the road
remember that's been a metric that's
actually been very good for those teams
one negative in the last ten years in
October
Aaron yet let's say Aaron Rodgers is 16
and OH
straight up at home in October but only
11 and 7 against the spread I talking
about the buys we have a few teams
coming off buys bills are at home after
a buy which is a little bit scary as
we've talked about before Colts are home
after a bye as well taking on the Texans
I will note I looked back last year
Colts after a bye also played at home
last year and they took on the Jaguars
and they really controlled that entire
game but there was a number of issues
that they had but they were able to they
got the push there and the Bears are a
home team after a bye which makes me
like the Saints even more after what we
thought oh yeah cuz I want Mitchell to
Biscay coming in like four days before
the game like that just made me circle
the Saints a little bit more just so
well so far in this show we've talked
about strength of schedule edges for the
Saints we've talked about EDS are or the
Saints now we got the bye week trend
going for the Saints as well the scary
part about the Saints of course it is
probably going to be one of the
strongest public sides and the Bears
have a really what you think that a lot
of people are gonna bet on the sites I
take some points in Chicago against
Rubin I mean it's a team that's only
lost one game out of six a team that
went to you know has it has been able to
win on the road they just went on the
road last week in grass in the hot
weather and we're still able to win that
game against Gardner Minshew
and the Jaguars now they play the Bears
yeah you know I think I think the
public's probably going to be on the
Saints this week publics not always
wrong no they're not always wrong
they're not say what the fact that in
the super contest
I get the Saints at plus three and a
half I get that little half point we had
the hay is like
points okay four o'clock the game that
we circled our two teams that I feel
like you've had your fingers on the
pulse of them all year Ravens at Sea
Hawks two teams that historically this
would have been a defensive shootout
now it's an offensive display Ravens are
oh four and one against the spread in
their last five games it's been the
Lamar Jackson show you have said that it
might get a little bit harder for him
there's one guy coming back that I'm not
seeing anyone talk about Seahawks are
getting to Ron Reed back from his six
game suspension Patrick Peterson's
coming back from his six game suspension
cheer on Reed Jadeveon Clowney is the
most double-teamed player in the NFL
right now you can't do that what you're
on Reno we don't know what his
conditionings gonna be I'm sure he's
gonna be on the oxygen tank and a third
but jaren Reed is a big-time player
former second-round pick I think he was
but a mauler from Alabama what I know
that you have a Pete Carroll versus
running quarterback statistic that's
gonna blow my top off what do we got
yeah it's pretty crazy so I went back
and looked obviously you know I have
connections are talking to some people
and some of the guys in Seattle we're
telling me how Pete Carroll's generally
done pretty good against running
quarterback so fortunately I've got a
database I mean look it up and as it
turns out to what I did is I went back
the last few years not like since 2012
or something but the last handful of
years and looked at what running
quarterbacks that he's faced and so
you've got Cam Newton you've got the
Shaun Watson you got Tyrod Taylor you
got Marcus Mariota you got Blake bortles
and you got dak Prescott now for the
time being I'm gonna stick that Prescott
in his own little box and right wrap it
up set over here we'll talk about that
he doesn't always a mobile quarter he
doesn't run as much as he should the
Dallas Cowboys one of the flaws they
need to be running dak a little bit more
offshore such an edge but at any rate
he's in this box over here we're looking
at the other guys so I only went back
and looked because they play Cam
Newton's so often like five times well
they played in more than five I just
looked at the last five so like the last
like four years the five games at ease
played yeah plus all these other guys
have played him once
and lo and behold I found out that the
Seattle Seahawks have won five of the
nine games against those guys
however Seattle is three and six against
the spread when they play running
quarterbacks and the most interesting
nugget to me about when they're playing
these running quarterbacks because keep
in mind who they got russell wilson is
that these games have not gone over at a
sixty or seventy or an eighty or ninety
percent clip but a 100 percent clip
every single game where they've played
one of these running quarterbacks has
gone over the posted total and what what
is it how many games nine and oh wow
nineteen oh so you can so it's gone over
nine and oh and this week they're
playing lamar jackson who just ran for
over a hundred and fifty yards he's more
dangerous than all those other
quarterbacks all of them from a rushing
perspective pure rushing perspective i
mean obviously we know cam and his peak
cam was great at throwing the football
and could run it too right Lamar's not
two cams level of peak cam throwing the
football Lamar's not there yet but Lamar
is more dangerous running the football
right now then probably so this is a
trend that you're seeing that's not
about sides it's not about against the
spreads but you're looking at an
over/under ratio of nine and no over
when Pete Carroll has played true
running quarter yes so the dak Prescott
one okay when dak played them three
times in the last few years when DAC
rained the ball for three or fewer times
both those games went under when he ran
it at least five times that game went
over so you know when Dad what do you
think it is about that defense that's
just susceptible to it do they just
allow it to happen it's it's just hard I
know that you're Patrick disables went
over last year to you think that you're
practicing yeah and I don't include
Patrick mom's in here but he definitely
has some wheels and can get around when
you're practicing against a Russel
Wilson you would think that like you
would be dealing with the actual can
float what Russell Wilson tends to do
and I doubt that he runs in practice
much as he only runs when he needs to
run you're right he sauce up in the
pocket and he looks and he looks and
even when he's about to cross the line
he's still looking to make that first
yeah he does not really want to run the
football and he I was happy when I saw
him the other day because he looked a
little bit faster earlier this season
and toward the end of last season he
just looked a little bit different to me
running less Mobe
I'm a banged up with some injuries and
so I think he wants to run the football
in more high leverage situations and
less frequently but so he they probably
aren't practicing it quite as much
against that but that's the other thing
when you're talking about the Baltimore
Ravens it minimizes the pass rush a
little bit because they don't pass the
ball a ton and they're real dangerous
when they run the football and they keep
those edge wrestlers at bay with some of
the read option type stuff they will
leave a Jadeveon Clowney or honoré
unblocked we don't even gonna block you
I'm happy you're back we're not gonna
block you we're just gonna make you
wrong whatever you do we're gonna make
you wrong on this read option play so
shoot out this Sunday at 4 o'clock there
are some other edges to this game you
know if you look at just the pure
metrics ok let me just give you a few of
the most pure metrics here these are two
top 12 early down success rate offenses
against two bottom three early down
success you might not think that the
Ravens have a bottom three EDS our
defense but they do you might not think
that the Seattle Seahawks have a bottom
three EDS our defense but they do this
is two top five red zone offenses
against two average red zone defenses
this is two top for overall offenses
versus to below average overall defenses
this is two top nine explosive passing
offenses against to below average
explosive passing defenses this is two
top three running back passing offenses
versus the number 11 and the number 31
running back pass defense the Baltimore
Ravens are terrible defending running
back passes they ranked second worst in
the NFL drop this mic thank you holy
[ __ ] that felt like an eight mile
freestyle right there but they do you
think they're not but they do alright
let me give you two final nuggets holy
[ __ ] you got more Nuggets to final
nuggets when an opponent scores over 17
points the Baltimore Ravens have gone
eight and two to the over the last two
years including seven and OH - the over
when the Marge axon is the quarterback
okay a nugget for the Seahawks in their
last 15 games the Seahawks are 12 and 3
- the over there only games under the
total have been versus the inept
Cardinals offense in week for the inept
Bengals offense in week 1 and the
Vikings offense on Monday Night Football
week 14 of 2018 so you don't think that
these teams are like over teams right
here there are some things like they're
the most over teams in the sport it
sounds any time that you're handicapping
a game you and this is for the people
who are learning about this with us you
can't just look at the positives you
have to look at some of the negatives
there is some rain potentially in this
forecast fortunately the winds are not
too bad but there is some rain you also
have a Kerala [ __ ] best you also have
a kicking issue with the Seattle
Seahawks their field goal kickers is not
super reliable right now so that is an
issue
the Ravens is the most relevant is great
although he totally cost me one time
when he missed an extra point against
the Saints last yeah that was just
brutal cuz we got the announcers like he
has never missed an extra point in his
career and then he shanks it so that was
terrible but I kind of look like Justin
Tucker a little bit well I definitely
cannot sing like Justin Tucker do not
put me up there trying to sing a song
because Tucker is gonna ask you to it's
good now you know me all right Sunday
Night Football
Eagles Cowboys little note Cowboys are
seven and one straight up in their last
eight games at home that is in Dallas on
Sunday night Cowboys are four and now
against the Eagles with Zeke oh and two
with Adam obviously is playing Eagles
have held their opponents primary rusher
to thirty point one rushing yards per
game I want to see if there's any other
notes that I have here that I want to
get in Cowboys have beaten the Eagles
three straight but all three have been
less than seven points and the Eagles
how about this and their last seven
games as a road underdog have won five
of them outright they love being an
underdog where do you want to start and
finish with this game just from an
analytics perspective well jumped out to
you what jumped out to me the most was
what Philly has done in Dallas recently
okay because both of these teams are in
must-win situations I mean this game is
gonna be so dope it's gonna have the
feel of like chicken for championship
game like it's not the Superbowl but
it's you're you got two teams from the
same conference and only one of them's
gonna get to go both three and three
Cowboys are coming off three straight
losses Jason Garrett is being
Doug Peterson in his Monday radio show
says we're gonna win I went and looked
at the Dallas Cowboys reaction they're
already pissed we'll see on the field
that's easy to see from a press
conference this is going to be a
monstrous occasion I want all the 33%
everybody that is listening to this
podcast on your phone everybody that's
watching this on YouTube make an
appointment on your couch 8:20 p.m.
Eastern Time Sunday night this game is
gonna be epic I truly believe this kind
of game is gonna be superb and but the
interesting thing is Philadelphia Eagles
they've played obviously once a year in
Dallas
they've gone 3 & 2 straight up in Dallas
in the last five games their two losses
both went to overtime this Eagles team
could be five and OH in Dallas the last
five years Wow and but we know like a
round there last year they took away
that opening kickoff fumble from us
we'll never forget it last year there
were two debacles in the game and
there's no other way to put it but a
total debacle the first debacle occurred
on a muffed kick where five Eagles
jumped on the board and Lewis fumbled
the ball
Camus grew J Hill came out of the pile
with it there was only five Eagles in
the pile and they said it was
inconclusive evidence of that they are
they came out with the ball yeah nothing
we didn't have any memory immediate
recovery and the guy showed the football
meanwhile the only guys in the pile or
the Philadelphia Eagles it's basically
impossible for that to not go the eagle
you are the two losses in overtime and
then the second debacle was the big boy
Dallas got hurt yeah catch is a 75 yard
touchdown oh yeah the like that the
field yeah scores and they call it back
due to offensive pass interference
because as he was running past a slow
safety the the to facemask on their
helmet collided a little bit and so the
guys face mask went just like that and
they called an offensive pass
interference on that and wiped off a 75
yard touch on that game the
Speight those two things which one of
them would have given the Eagles the
ball like at the 25 or 30 yard of Dallas
the other one was actually seven points
despite that the game goes to overtime
Dallas ends up scoring a touchdown and
winning so this game I mean there are
definitely some interesting matchups but
the biggest thing to me is not the
matchups the biggest thing to me is the
injury issues that the Dallas Cowboys
currently are dealing with right now and
I need to see what this Thursday were
injury portrait is telling me because if
the ironsmith halala columns are out
again and and I'm hearing from some of
the reporters down there with good
connections that both of their starting
tackles Lyle's Collins and Tyrone Smith
are both out this week Wow okay and we
don't know about Amari Cooper banged up
yeah
bruised his calf but was supposedly in
extreme physical pain after that game
last week in New York he obviously left
the game whether he's back I mean the
good thing is it's just a calf but
you're a wide receiver you obviously
need to use your calf muscle and so
there's questions as to whether or not
he's gonna play he did not practice on
Wednesday and in addition well let's
first talk about those injuries right
yes those are the offensive injuries for
the Dallas Cowboys and what is the
weakness of your Eagles defense the keel
each second there is the second area
it's the work defense yeah you've got
injuries there you're hopefully getting
some guys that are going to be coming
back but I don't think they're back yet
and you could pass the ball on these
guys look at what the Minnesota Vikings
did that's why I knew last week we
mentioned on your show that it was
difficult for me to view the
Philadelphia Eagles week six going up to
Minnesota and winning that game I said
if this game was played in week 15 I
might be able to see it I think they
could but in week six this week with the
injuries in their secondary I felt like
it wasn't a good spot for the Eagles
and what did Minnesota do they didn't
run the ball particularly well because
the cowboy the Eagles have a very good
run defense didn't have a good day
but I knew the play action game was
going to eat up that secondary and of
course it did so what happens here when
the Dallas Cowboys do not have both
their tackles to pass protect for dak
and don't have their number one wide
receiver you can't take advantage of the
issues with the Philadelphia Eagles
secondary
nearly as much what else is another
layer to talk about with the passing
matchup is that the Dallas Cowboys have
stopped running play-action
they've halved halved not have hav e but
half H al VD yeah they've have their
usage of play-action for whatever reason
from the first three weeks to the last
three weeks they were using play-action
nearly as much that's going to hurt
their ability to attack that secondary
what is your thought we were praising
the offensive coordinator felony weeks
where do you think he stands now I think
that something interesting is going on
there I think people over his shoulder
right now
meddling what we do this a lot of times
where we go oh the offense wasn't great
under Jason Garrett or wasn't great
under what the what's his name the guy
that used to be the Rams head coach and
now he's been the offensive coordinator
for the Cowboys what's his name not the
current yeah what did it used to be no
not you knows about calling more talking
about the old before Callum or she has
slip in my mind all right whatever but
you how do we know if someone's meddling
or if Kelly Moore is just getting tight
and call a bad place to me it doesn't
matter because I care about what's gonna
happen here and so I played out both
scenarios in my mind okay the first
scenario is that Jason Garrett for
whatever reason after the first three
weeks went well started to metal and he
wanted things done a little bit
differently and so Kellen Moore's
calling stuff the way that Jason Garrett
wants it done what ends up happening in
this game do you think Jason Garrett's
all of a sudden just gonna say well my
involvement here was a real disaster so
you just take over I'm not gonna have
anything to do with it
I really doubt the Jason Garrett would
do that I think the same pattern would
continue that scenario one Jason Garrett
was meddling scenario two is Jason
Garrett wasn't meddling mhm and yet the
first three weeks are good the last
three weeks weren't good what do you
think's gonna happen
Jason Garrett is gonna start meddling
right if Jason Garrett hasn't been he's
going to start getting involved so in
either case whether Jason Garrett was
involved or was not involved previously
I think he's probably going to be
involved and that is a bad thing for the
Dallas Cowboys I think so too
all right you've given more information
than I think our brains can handle I
think the strength of schedule stuff it
was awesome
ETS our matchups have been great the
three games you just did here I've
listened to you I've kind of narrowed it
down to about eight teams that I've
circled that I'm thinking for my super
contest sites it's not often that I like
the Eagles
I don't like betting them a lot but plus
two and a half and the rant you just
went on has me excited it's three you're
not getting 3 and the super contest I'm
looking at it right here
it's [ __ ] down to two and a half you
mean that's line they published so they
must have known that we were trending in
this direction is that upsetting is that
something that like I mean I want the
three I know that they have good success
down in Dallas but knock is that a half
a point enough to scare me away from it
it should lower it from a definitely on
your card to let me put it in the maybe
goes on the card Wow
okay that's fair I have starred and this
was my number one heading into this was
Jaguars minus three and a half at
Bengals like all the things that you're
telling me right now are lining up I
don't like the half a point that I have
to deal with but I have a lot of heart
for Gardner Minshew
in the matchups that he's faced we were
saying now the Bengals yeah we talked
about that one how it's gonna be a much
easier schedule for him and how
difficult he's so let me just say this
dark has Denard is supposedly coming off
pu p we have no idea who he's gonna be
but they've just lost William Jackson
for a few weeks a corner they just lost
trade Kirkpatrick there are other
options right now our Tony McCray and
Torrey McTeer two journeyman corner
backs that again and they just lost
Shawne Williams has a swelling issue one
of their safeties so he just talks about
mint you haven't faced the Broncos the
Panthers the Saints now they're facing
the 29th adjusted sack rate Bengals plus
an absolutely destroyed defensive
backfield
I like the Jaguars another one I circled
the Niners minus nine and a half the
revenge game all that stuff I know it's
a big line I don't think it's that big I
really don't I think they can handle it
Torrey McTeer yes that's that's a real
that's a real guy
I was like Tony the Tiger from frosted
flakes Tori McCormack tyre the other one
I guess I had the Eagles now I have to
think about it at the half point I do
like the Raiders plus four and a half
that line was Green Bay minus seven and
a half it's down to four and a half but
with Oakland off the by and how I think
they're gonna come out there and that
the the Packers on a short week off
Monday Night Football I it's a number
that I still like and I'm willing to
take the risk that Aaron Rodgers doesn't
jump out to an early lead to begin him
playing game flow there the other ones
that I had I know it's a public bet
Saints plus three and a half that extra
half a point I kind of liked it a lot
and my three maybes is Seattle minus
three it's a shootout and I'd rather
trust the Saints the Seahawks in a
shootout at home than the Lamar Jackson
team on the road to shoot out the Giants
because of your EDS our rankings but
again that's another shootout where I'm
hoping that the home team has the
advantage there and the other one is in
D minus 1 in D minus one against Houston
it's a game that it's gonna be very even
but I go against Houston last week I
think this is where Frank Reich has
really owned Bill O'Brien in recent
years and that's been with Jacoby
Brissette or with Andrew Luck and I know
that Indies coming off a bye in there at
home but this is Frank Reich and I trust
good coaches off of my and I take
advantage of bad coaches off of bye if
that makes any sense it does make sense
you what you I know that Frank Wright
came out and told his players that
mentally we want you guys checked into
this week we don't want you checked out
no travel and I forgot I forgot to say
this Darius Leonard is back yep Clayton
Clayton gathers T Y Hilton hold on I
need to find this because it was I had
so many stats on this game
Darius Leonard came gathers is back
Malik hooker there's a chance he can
play Jabal sheered get back before the
buy their best pass rusher Texans just
lost Bradley Roby and offensive lineman
lineman Titus Howard Jonathan javis has
a hamstring issue Indianapolis right now
is fourth and adjusted sack rate Houston
is 25th so Indies gonna be able to
protect their quarterback Houston not so
much all
so since the Saints opener Houston has
had slow starts they started down 17 7
at the Chargers they started doubt this
is on the road down 17 to 3 at the
Chiefs
if they start down to the Colts it's the
Marlin Mac show who just had a bye week
to get healthy on that ankle T why
Hilton last six games against Houston
five for 85 nine for 199 for for 115 3
for 14 5 for 172 and 2 touchdowns 9 for
115 in one touchdown T Y Hilton eats
against Romeo Crennel he owns he eats he
got the deed to Romeo Crennel to his
body his soul and his spirit DeAndre
Hopkins last two games against in d5 437
for 436 in a touchdown and Matty birf
loses this is from Silva cover to
defense limits deep passing and that
limits will fuller
I like the Colts a lot in this game I
really do that like I started looking up
numbers I was like correlation causation
give them all to me so I like that one a
lot
and the Colts look they've had a very
tough defensive schedule they ranked
28th in efficiency not very good but
they've played the seventh toughest
schedule of opposing offenses darn
they've they faced a very difficult
schedule from that perspective all right
let's call crack because we got to get
Warren to run out of here and do his
train really quick so we're gonna make
this quick
you just had so much good [ __ ]
information today bro it's a jacket baby
it is do you have a name for that jacket
Excalibur when I put it on I assume the
powers of the jacket what do you think
you think about the card overalls we
wait for crack is it a car that you
think is juicy I like it better than
I've liked the last couple of cards okay
yeah for sure
I've got a few games that I've already
jumped on there's a few more to come I
feel like you've hinted at a few of them
today already I'm we're trying to help
the guys
yeah old cracky poos hello
oh you've called Moviefone
congratulations but there's one movie
you didn't get to see this year are you
interested in free tickets to Joker on
Saturday at 7:30 that sounds like a
scene from Seinfeld
damn it yeah what up crack hey how you
doing brother Cosmo Kramer
alright so crack I'm gonna give you the
food right I'm gonna give you the floor
right away here my man crack wins what
are some games that you've circled for
the good people of 33% I will let you go
first
you know I haven't talked to war about
anything this week but I'll tell you I
just don't see the dolphins getting 17
points from Buffalo I don't know if I'm
a buffalo could score 17 I know they I
mean I shouldn't say that they're there
there is much improved team this year
but you know the Dolphins have been
getting a lot of points from a lot of
good team around this many points 17
points 21 points from some really good
teams and just to see them get 17 from
Buffalo this doesn't look right on paper
to me so I may be going with it with
Miami these are our final selections
course off from an official standpoint
of the better of the line because you
get a better line by it you're picking
in the contest rather than betting at
the window Minnesota - one Minnesota -
one is a very good a very good line over
Detroit but yet Detroit's a tougher team
this year probably should have won the
other day against the Green Bay division
games usually do favor the home team
though so I'm I'm still looking into
that pretty much I'm looking at going
against the public here I think people
are just think the San Fran's like the
greatest team on one of the greatest
teams in football I don't know it just
seems like a lot of points everyone's
gonna be on San Fran and maybe looking
into Washington a little bit going down
the schedule Seattle may be over
Baltimore
I think Baltimore's defense can be given
up some points here I think I think
Seattle it might be a good good
side of the game there I'm not oh this
is the three also is a good line - three
yes that was that yeah okay finally get
down to the the Eagles which Peterson
said publicly accorded to Dallas to win
so again Cooper may be out over there
the players are kind of revolting over
there in Dallas do like walking by the
coach not even like acknowledging
himself yeah I might be a little bit of
up in arms or with the Cowboys so kind
of looking at their haven't made no
official plays and yeah so what are you
looking at so I'll tell you what I
definitely am looking at Philadelphia I
wish it was at three and not two and a
half
Seattle has definitely caught my
attention I just went on an epic rant
about why I love indie - one I just it's
it's just sticking out to me and I I
guess I am the public that is as feeling
the 49ers and the nine and a half crack
it's it's a little bit of the Kyle
Shanahan revenge game it's a little bit
of Washington being obsessed with
running the ball and the Niners run
defense being so darn good so I I kind
of feel like Washington's about to enter
the wood chipper and then the Jaguars at
- three and a half is a team that I go
maybe we're under estimating the
defenses that Gardner Minshew faced the
last few weeks and now he gets the
Bengals and it might be the DJ shark
show on Sunday no team has cost me more
money in the NFL this year than
Jacksonville Jacksonville just as I just
cost me so much money this year on
barley cards and and just even banging
them straight up which I really don't
like it'll been a lot of game straight
up really bad against the Saints last
week and the Saints have been yes sharp
killer this season the Saints have been
yes ver stamp of the week before they
got me to going back let's go back to
your to your pick on on the San Fran
Washington game you know I'm probably
not going to play it now just based on
if you go with washing San Fran I
probably true for you because I
I don't want to go against you but not
but uh not only that this is a it's a
Sunday contest anything could happen in
these games I just looked at earlier in
the season you know what would this game
have been a nine and a half point line
and he definitely wouldn't but then
again what was really warm had a future
against Washington under six and a half
we almost took that Washington Redskins
as the team to win the fewest games but
we knew that the Dolphins were just
going to be so bad that we didn't but we
definitely took under six and a half
yeah to win maybe the division or they
were they were predicted to be third
place in that division we took them over
wins and then we also put a little bit
on them to win the division that's a
juicy go back to I'll go back to the
Indianapolis Colts game Wow you I think
you've done well on the coast this year
if I mind
that's me right and III think that
that's a good did the Colts hat off last
week right that if I would they did this
is this is a good spot for them I I may
I may join you on that Colts side after
Houston going into he's willing a tough
game and III may join you on that so
yeah we got some good stuff circled on
the card this week and hopefully we'll
get there all right so I'm gonna I'll
text you again tomorrow night you guys
text me at like 5:00 and go hey [ __ ]
don't forget to text us and then I'll
text you it'll be great
okay good good good we'll get this done
for you and I'm actually flying to
Philly but I got buddy here to put these
in so it's no problem
I'm flying into the for the ESPN fights
tomorrow but anyway good yeah it sounds
good I look forward to it look forward
to talking to you guys next week again
you're the man crack thanks again dude
you're the best proxy in the world
thanks crack see a man and as always you
can download the crack winds app I know
he gives out a free pic every week he
kind of breaks it down and crack looks
at it more like where are the lines the
most juicy he loves to follow movement
and then from that movement he's just
one of those insanely educated betters
where he sees movement he takes
advantage of movement smart but you know
you're
you're the king of the castle Warren the
king of the castles got a little bit of
a thing for the 33% this week what do
you think a sharp 33 Oh time out you
know what I'm going to do it 33 percent
off really you you got on me for the
other week like not doing enough so 33
percent off this week wait so if the
listener goes to your website and a
sharp 33 they get 33% off yep damn guys
he didn't even tell me you're gonna do
that you didn't tell me you're gonna do
that
no I didn't but and I appreciate you bro
they appreciate you we all appreciate
you and I man this is still like my
favorite thing to do every week I'm just
I'm learning a lot and I'm learning how
not to be a square and I appreciate it
I brought some you brought some heat too
so well Engelberg gave me a little
information and then I had a few daddy
cigars last night and I just sat on my
bed till about 2:30 in the morning and
just looked up statistics talking to
yourself in a movie phone voice no I
okay let's play that music 33 percent
you guys to the [ __ ] follow sharp
football
check out sharp football analytics sharp
33 you get 33% off and I'm just telling
you that I feel a lot safer when I go on
a sharp football analytics and I see
that Warren and I are on the same side I
feel a lot more confident with my bets
for Warren sharp on the lef koe Man we
will holler at you next week